[Musik]
das hatte der 24-jährige 24er fürchten
uns nicht wir 24er verzweifeln nicht der
24er tun
[Musik]
wird sie doch mal mit sonnencreme
verstanden
[Musik]
der mann am berg unterwegs ist dass es
immer einsatz das wetter ändert sich
viel schneller und das spiel extrem
[Musik]
durch lawinen ich immer gewisse gefahr
doch die gilt es zu minimieren
[Musik]
der rückstoß aber es ist schon das
kleine city wo man fühlt sich schon vor
der wahl anfang
[Musik]
in unserem bereich und gewinn schließen
sagt malanik sondern eben auch jäger
scharfschützen aufklärer und das ist ja
das besondere verantwortung wenn man mit
den fingern saugen und truppen schießen
könnte
[Musik]
83 sekunden später vor die granate aus
und die druckwelle immer am körper hat
sowie ein drittel nie bewusst
[Musik]
wer eigenschaften braucht es disziplin
die liebe zur natur durchhaltevermögen
und die ruhe
[Musik]
wir haben in diesen zwei wochen soldaten
und kommandanten aller ebenen bis zur
erschöpfung gefördert die aufgabe eine
sehr große aber die mannschaft hat sich
nicht geflüchtet
sie ist daran nicht gescheitert und
somit kann ich sagen 24 auf der welt
[Musik]